one of the most important languages of  Africa is hausa which is the most widely  spoken native language in Nigeria and  Niger and is also spoken in Chad and  some other countries it's spoken by  around 50 million people as a first  language it's a member of The Chadwick  branch of the afro-asiatic language  family its basic word order is SVO and  it has three tones high low and falling  this means they're smoking tobacco word  for word it's they are smoking tobacco  Sunnah is a subject pronoun used  specifically for the present continuous  notice that Sunnah has a high tone than  a low tone Shan has a falling tone and  taba has a high tone than a low tone  there are a lot of Arabic words in hausa  both from contact with North Africa and  from the Quran most hausa speakers are  Muslims for example a greeting meaning  good day or good afternoon  word for word it's greeting of day or  sun Buttercup comes from Arabic Baraka  which means Blessing by the way did you  know that